the insane missing pieces of what
happened at marijuana the murder of a
Celestial Dragon the secret identity of
king of the world imusama revealed and
much more is coming up in this insanist
of chapters trust me so make sure to
stay tuned for this one channel parking
with it and smash that like button if
you enjoy these one piece reviews and
want to keep them coming make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and of course spoilers
ahead now we get my favorite kind of
color spread this chapter showing off
the sexy ladies of one piece with nami
in the Forefront and that's always
appreciated by metaculture like myself
but the chapter itself called the
attempted murder of a Celestial Dragon
starts inside the castle at marijua Sabo
is handling some father characters like
they're nothing and like expected he
runs into Bonnie a good pair to be sure
I like their Dynamic personally Bonnie
recognizes him and says she thinks
they're both after the same thing so
they should skip the small talk and
pretty much just get to it it's revealed
that they stole the slave collar Keys
which of course they did because they
both want a free Kuma it's a weird
choice that Oda let Kuma return to
marijua and now is showing us all the
trouble they went to just to free him in
the first place the whole Kuma returning
to Marie joa thing better have an
interesting conclusion but yeah we gotta
trust anoda the two run and talk as Sabo
remarks that he heard about Kuma having
a daughter Bonnie for her part always
kept tabs on revolutionary activity so
she knows Sabo is trustworthy she says
she'll leave it to them to save her
dad's body and take it to safety love
seeing characters we know separately
from each other coming together like
this and just having a great Convoy in
Dynamic the one piece world is just so
satisfying in this way Sabo gives keys
to one of karasu's crows and tells him
to tell morally to get Kuma and the
others back to HQ as soon as they're
free karasu asks about Sabo via Crow and
he says he'll be right behind them after
he's done here of course as We Know he
needs to be photographed next to Cobra's
dead body first the crow tells him to be
careful and then pieces out with the
keys Sabo asks about Bonnie's next moves
and she reveals as we saw that she's off
to Egghead to see whether vegapunk has a
way to restore dad's mind so interesting
seeing this flashback helping everything
else fall into place hope we get a
similar thing for the rocky Port
incident one day Bonnie also says I
quote if he can't dot dot dot
exclamation mark implying she's not
gonna forgive him then Sable acts
quickly when he hears more security guys
coming and takes Bonnie with him to the
ceiling where they hide Bonnie thinks
herself that she owes Sabo one as he
holds her in his arms like a new bride
the flame Emperor is definitely looking
smooth here then there are some convos
between the guards I'll let you guys
decide how relevant it is they say there
are fewer guards than ever around here
and another says haven't you heard you
can blame you know what for that so you
have another mystery being planted by
Oda then the legendary Phantom room is
meant while another says don't talk
nonsense notably though Sabo pays close
attention to this conversation I'm
definitely curious about this Phantom
room and its properties now there's no
way it would be mentioned for no reason
Sabo then wishes Bonnie luck on her
Voyage since they're heading in
different directions and she says he's
so friendly for a radical revolutionary
nothing new in one piece can't judge
someone by their label and Sabo says of
course they are working to save the same
person and she asks him one more time to
look after her dad for her except they
do a bad job as mentioned he's on his
way back to marijua but I trust that Oda
has his reasons and it will be
satisfactory at the end then we start
with the truly insane and most crazy
game-changing part of the chapter Cobra
is in the room with the five Elders he's
come to ask something we start with some
backstory that the organization of the
world government was founded 800 years
ago when 20 different monarchs came
together their families all promptly
moved to Marie show up to live as one
clan referred to as the celestial
dragons the ones responsible for the
create nation of the world and as such
they have ruled over their creation ever
since internally the 20 were considered
equal and to ensure that no individual
dictator would rise up among them they
installed the empty Throne a fascinating
idea but also one that begs someone to
rise up and finally just sit at it I'm
looking at you imusama we see that each
of them placed a weapon around the
throne to symbolize their vow to never
try and sit upon it at the same time new
royal families were hand-picked to rule
the Nations that the founders could no
longer preside over those families are
still empowered to this day in order to
ensure the smooth transition all
references mentioning the previous
Dynasty's Reign were removed from each
of the founders respective home
countries very orwellian not to mention
similar to attack on Titan if you know
you know now it gets really interesting
Cobra says with the sole exception of
alabasta the Monarch at the time was
Queen Lily of house nefertari note her
silhouette here it'll be important later
does it look like anyone else you know
we're further told that despite her name
being immortalized is one of the
founding 20 she did not stay to become a
Celestial Dragon but hear me out perhaps
she did stay as we'll see soon but for
now Cobra says instead she was to return
to Alabaster to continue her Reign which
is why the nefertari family has
continued to act as sovereigns this also
means that only 19 weapons were ever
placed around the empty throne but
remember the weapons were placed as a
way of saying I won't sit here so if she
didn't Place one perhaps it was because
she planned to sit there again as we'll
see for now though the elders say but
what is your point bro Cobra says he
scoured the ancient texts but all known
accounts chronicling the period after
the void Century have one thing in
common her name isn't mentioned once in
other words she just vanished and just
think about who has a habit of making
things vanish he says Queen Lily never
made it home and the burden of ruling
the country fell to her younger brother
he asks them if they have a record of
what became of her and I'm just thinking
you know too much Cobra and you're
asking all the wrong questions if you
want to live no wonder this dude wound
up dead the elders say to be blunt 800
years is a very long time ago it is true
that of the 20 families the nefertari
line did not move here however it was
believed that the queen returned back to
her country after that decision I'm
sorry but I'm afraid that details about
her motives and journey are lost to the
annals of History we simply do not know
but Cobra isn't satisfied he says in
that case what is the meaning of d and
then of course the elders get serious
asking why do you ask he says the truth
is a short letter penned by the queen
has been passed down from one generation
to the next now the wording is a bit
weird and I look forward to seeing the
viz translation but it seems like Lily
started the D thing but why and what
significance does it hold I can't wait
to see we then jump to Celestial Dragon
Charles just continuing to be the worst
this dude is just so fun to hate now
he's using slave Kuma to tie up and hurt
shirahoshi he wants her as a pet as we
know he wants to ride her every single
day he says and if she doesn't listen
she'll know nothing but pain what a
maniac this dude is shirahoshi begs for
help while a bunch of cowards run away
wanting to avoid trouble saying they
didn't see a thing not a lot of people
are willing to start something with a
Celestial Dragon even if they are acting
horribly luckily big brother comes to
rescue saying let's go home and never
come back to this rotten place as he's
about to attack Charles the latter gives
the order for his Invincible slave Kuma
to do away with a small fry and in the
meantime it's commented how much warlord
Kuma has fallen still waiting to see
exactly why Kuma felt it was necessary
to get to this point AKA The Fault at
this point and that reminds me Oda is
sure taking his sweet time with that
Kuma flashback that was teased when
Bonnie entered his memories Charles
doesn't care about non Celestial royalty
he wants to kill shirahoshi's people
saying they'll bury anyone who complains
in money and even says it doesn't matter
because they're just fish that punch
Luffy delivered just gets more and more
satisfying in retrospect after every new
chapter with Charles in it for now the
Royal Prince fukaboshi is asked to show
restraint but that doesn't stop
non-royals from hitting him muscard even
says he'll take full responsibility he
also points out that it's better if
pirates hit the Celestial Dragon because
escaping is easier when you don't have a
country so in the end sir Leo captain of
the fifth ship of the straw hat Grand
Fleet and PSY captain of the third ship
of the straw hat Grand Fleet make their
move love to see Luffy's followers
continuing where he left off they launch
brutal attacks and hit Charles right on
the head like it literally looks like
Luffy's awakened devil fruit is being
used Charles looks way too cartoonish as
he is squished to an impossible degree
Witnesses are sure that must have killed
him and it definitely looks like it
should have if normal Anatomy was a
thing in one piece it said they murdered
a Celestial Dragon and that an admiral
is gonna show up for sure love to see
Charles get this kind of punishment no
one deserves it more unfortunately the
title attempted murder of a Celestial
Dragon implies he might still be alive
don't ask me how but that's the
implication at least then Morley appears
in typical Morley style hugging Kuma and
saying stop picking on kumachan he tells
Kuma with tears and snot and everything
that he doesn't have to listen to
anyone's orders anymore let's go home
the onlookers all this time are just so
shocked so far they've seen what looks
like a murder of a Celestial Dragon in
other words of a God and then they just
see a giant pop out of nowhere the crow
delivers morally the keys from Sabo and
then they head down using Morley's power
and then Charles's dad says look how
they massacred my boy killing a
Celestial Dragon is definitely badass
even if he ends up Surviving and cool to
see the grand Fleet following the spirit
of Luffy like this as if Luffy is here
even when he's not then we jump to
easily the biggest craziest most
important part of this chapter imusama
the most mysterious of figures is
walking up to the empty Throne don't
forget emu is not the only one there
right now emu is told that king cobra is
still present as Cobra is shocked to see
the so-called great emu sit on the
throne imusama says Lily dot dot dot and
sits on the throne with no hesitation
craziness Insanity obviously this makes
it look like imusama as many have
speculated is not only a woman but the
Lily that disappeared so long ago she
didn't put a sword there because she
went to sit on the throne and Rule from
the Shadows now Oda is definitely making
it look like this and it may be
purposeful misdirection but now you
definitely can't blame anyone for
jumping to the conclusion that imusama
is this long-lost queen of alabasta and
that would make her the now Immortal
king of the world over 800 years old it
also makes more sense why emu would be
holding a picture of Vivi so the
craziness and the hype for the next
chapter and for the answers that Lily or
imusama will reveal are off the charts
also loved seeing the revolutionaries
continue to shine this chapter and if
you love them too then you don't want to
miss my Monkey D dragon and his
Commander's explain video link on screen
right now and in the description see you
there